let me start by saying how much i love
this movie and your performance in it
um i just want to say you did such great
work
jumping into this when you're getting
ready for a role like this
in a role that like denzel has played in
the past
how much are you saying i want to look
at his work
and sort of look at it and how much are
you like i never please don't show me
that or even a frame of it
until after i've i've finished yeah just
just just as i was just as the audition
came through
there was a moment where i was like do i
watch the spike film or do i
and i was no no no i don't think i need
it because i feel like
it's pretty clear when you read this
that it's a it's a
it's a different malcolm i think what
was that
regina and i really connected on that
idea that this
this is malcolm in private with his
friends
you know in love and joy and friendship
in a really vulnerable situation a real
spot of
such huge shifts going on for malcolm in
his in his
thinking his religious thinking his
political thinking and
and so no i i
i uh
no i put my attention in a completely
different direction
and i was kind of excited by the idea
that there was there was an opportunity
to play malcolm in such a different
setting um so yeah
um the there's a speech in the film the
the line in the sand speech
it's very passionate and it's very
powerful um
can you sort of talk about prepping to
do a scene like that
and getting yourself in that mental head
space yeah well we were shooting those
long scenes
all in different orders and you know
we'd
do bits you know trying to stay
on top of the emotional journey became a
real
that was the main concentration because
we were jumping back and forward and
around and
the great thing about working with
regina and the kind of fluid
sort of even relaxed atmosphere that she
created for the
for the actors was that all of these
really happy kind of accidents
happened and i had no intention of
playing
that moment like that at all in kemp's
script it never
it doesn't say he's raging or his voice
or emotion
nothing it was just eli was
i sam leaves the room and i went to the
window and
eli came over and eli was just
annoying me you know as the character
and he was poking me and
something just flipped and i just wanted
to get away from him
and then it just sort of unraveled and
and i only tell you that story because
i'm like that's
only because regina allowed for that
type of work to happen
she allowed for that kind of that danger
where we were allowed to we were allowed
to try things out a lot and we were
allowed to
you know move and shift and shape and
and play
uh it shows uh because all the
performances in the film are just so
effing good
you know um i have nothing but positive
things to say but
um talk a little bit about the staging
of a lot of the scenes
and what it was like behind the scenes
because a lot you know a lot of it takes
place in a hotel room
obviously yeah we had to kind of get a
little bit creative about how we used
the space and to keep it dynamic and
make sure that we
we were moved moved around and we didn't
get stuck in the same positions and
but that was all kind of you know quite
simple we'd come in and we
would work it out and then it was really
important that you know we're filming
and continuity and stuff that you
you set out what you're going to do in
the rehearsal kind of in
the you know the bulge the bold strokes
and then you kind of have to
play within that framework for the rest
of the day or the rest of the week
depending on how long that scene shoots
for so
it was all good it was all good it was
it was um
you know that we you know we tussled and
we were figuring it out together and
you know some some scenes were easier
than others and and uh
but yeah blocking in the room it became
it was something we had to constantly
sort of negotiate and think about and be
like you've been in that chair let's
move here so we
you know trying to use the space in the
best way possible a lot of actors i've
spoken to that
are playing a a significant like a real
person like this
in a significant role uh will stay in
character all the time
from as much as they can uh did you do
that
or how much were you you know what i
mean yourself and talk a little bit
about
the balance of maintaining yourself
while also trying to stay in character
yeah i tried to stay in character as
much as i could um
it was a lot of listening and watching
and repeating i'd listen and repeat and
listen and repeat and
and from you know 90 of the time i would
i was sort of
quite noisy on set i was you know i was
that i was the one
i was you know i was reeling off
speeches from six in the morning all the
way through till
we wrapped and i guess it was kind of
annoying for
people some of the time but then some of
the time time it was really useful
because
you repeat malcolm's words out loud they
have a really
they can be really impactful and and and
often the stakes of what
he was saying was so
mind-blowingly like profound so
yeah i tried to sort of stay in a
semi-loose character definitely the
dialect for sure
you know i wasn't coming out of that and
the glasses stayed firmly on my face
you know for the two months and the hair
was helpful and uh
yeah just kind of staying stay in the
vibe as much as you can
i completely get it i already have to go
i'm just going to say again how much i
loved your work in this
i wish you nothing but the best thank
you